Please welcome from American Airlines
vice president of operations strategic
planning and performance an Moroni
and director operations schedule
and block planning Amit Shindai. Good morning.
Um so I hope your journey here was smooth and
I hope if you flew that it was on American
Airlines. So thank you for your business. Um my
name is Ann Moroni. I'm the vice president of
operations planning and performance at American
and I'm here with my colleague Amit Chandai who's
our director of operation strategic planning.
Our team's mission to put it simply is to build
the best possible plan for the airline that will
support our incredibly competitive network and
deliver reliably, efficiently, and safely for
you, our customers every day. Um, so with that,
we're really excited to talk to you about our
partnership with Palunteer today and what we've
been starting to do with Foundry and how we
transform the way that we actually build our
network. So nearly a hundred years of innovation
at American Airlines and it's led us to be the
largest um airline in the world carrying the most
passengers and operating the most flight than any
other airlines. 630,000 customers will fly on
us today. To put it in perspective, that's 220
million passengers a year. 6,500 flights, that's
about five times the size of the entire London
Heathrow operation will be operated today on
American. And we do this with a phenomenal team.
Um over 14,000 pilots, 24,000 flight attendants,
35,000 airport employees, and 6,000 mechanics who
will work 247 365 to run the operation safely. So,
our planning um bear with me for a minute. Imagine
you're at a gate ready to board your flight. For
that moment to happen, the planning has started
long in the making to ensure that that aircraft
is at that gate with the right crew with fueling,
catering, servicing on board, baggage and
cargo loaded, the flight plan ready to go,
security checks done, and the ground crew and
ground equipment ready to push your aircraft.
That planning starts month in advance and we'll
go all the way to the day of operation where an
integrated operation center will actually dispatch
your flight. It's an incredibly complex logistical
problem and um and unfortunately as you can
imagine many of of you in the room can relate
our current planning is incredibly um manual
uh incredibly sequential and unfortunately as
a result quite siloed. So from outdated UIs like
you can see on the screen, Excel spreadsheets,
attachments being sent via emails between teams,
we spend an inordinate amount of time trying to
actually build the best schedule we can. We rely
on expert planners to weigh thousands of different
variables and look at many different data points
to find the balance between profitability and
reliability. And as you can imagine, it doesn't
leave a whole lot of room for optimization.
Now our schedule build starts at the core of
it with demand. Making sure that our network
is the most competitive and can be to serve
our customers needs. But obviously a lot of
operational constraints need to factor in.
Fleet is a big part of it. Pilot hours,
gate and infrastructure, airspace conraint
constraint, the time we need on the ground to
maintain our aircraft and to turn our aircraft
at the airport. All of that is built by our
network planning team into a first version of a
schedule that will then be sent over to all of our
operational teams who will then provide feedback,
but also build their own plans, workforce plan,
workload plan, material plan, ground equipment
plan, and you name it. Unfortunately,
by the time a team finds an opportunity in the
schedule, it is often too late to build in their
original plan or the solution they have in mind
works great for them but does not actually work
for the enterprise. Fixing a crew issue could
actually cause a maintenance issue if it's not
thought through the right way. We have to solve
earlier in the process as a network and we have
to solve on a continuous basis. Time is against
us when we do this. Of course, the world changes
as we build those schedules. Things change and we
need to be dynamic and competitive to respond to
the market demands. So, we set out to partner with
Palunteer to completely redesign this workflow
and rethink the way that we do business. And it's
been an incredible journey. In just about a year,
we've already unlocked millions, tens of millions
of dollar value. Um the idea here is to actually
collect all of this data and integrate the
workflows between network planning and operations
planning and really unlock efficiencies that
otherwise would not have even been visible to
our people. The goal again here in what we've been
building is to do this continuously dynamically
because the world keeps evolving. So with that
I'm going to pass it to Amit who's going to take
you a little deeper into what we've built.
Thank you an good morning everyone. So for
the next five minutes, I want you to imagine
that you're the world's best airline scheduler,
right? There's a very simple homework problem in
front of us. We need to look at that incredibly
complex chart that Ant showed and we need to find
all the inefficient patterns in it and we need to
provide solutions from those patterns uh that
helps us operate a safe uh schedule, a reliable
schedule for our customers and most importantly a
profitable schedule as well. So what's an example
of a uh inefficient pattern right? So consider
this example uh I have a flight that is coming
into San Francisco tonight and there's a flight
departing early morning from San Francisco. Those
flight timings just are tight enough where the
same crew doesn't have adequate amount of rest in
between and so the same crew cannot operate the
flight that came in and they cannot operate the
flight that goes out. As a consequence, that crew
has to sit in San Francisco or be a lovely city
um for an extra day and we have to ferry in
another crew to operate the next day's flight.
That's a highly inefficient pattern, right? And
we have thousands and thousands of these embedded
and hidden in the schedules that we need to go
find. Over the last year or so, uh we've been on
a journey with Palunteer to try and reimagine our
workflows on how do we effectively identify these
issues, how do we localize where those issues
are happening and how do we actually fix them. So
there's a lot going on on the screen that this is
a solution we call vector. Uh it's it's obviously
built on Foundry otherwise they wouldn't be here.
um uh but it shows us sort of the the critical
information right like these are key performance
indicators at the top uh but there's something
really interesting that is happening on the left
hand side of your screen right so if you look at
the crew advisor uh module you will realize that
instead of us having to go hunt and peck where
these inefficiencies are those are actually being
surfaced to me right so these are recommendations
that the models are scanning the entire network on
and they're saying there's there's something that
I found you probably want to take a look at it.
So, let's let's go a little bit deeper into this.
As I'm sort of going in a layer deeper, uh
what I see is that it's recommending that my
San Francisco flight needs to be rettimed by
15 minutes, right? And you would think like,
okay, that's a really simple thing.
like what's the big deal in that right
um you should be doing that in any case problem is
this happens to be a notoriously difficult problem
uh that one flight ret time is going to
trigger a whole bunch of upstreams and
downstream constraints that now come into
conflict and I need a mechanism where I'm
starting to think through all of these different
possibilities as I work through the schedule
to help us with this there are models that are
integrated in the background that provide live
checks for me, right? And these checks are
looking at am I creating a gating issue? Am
I creating a turn issue? Am I violating any of my
standards? Am I violating any of my site barriers?
And those models are running continuously in the
background. Right? The the end result of this is
I'm going to come into this and you will realize
that it's actually identified a conflict for me.
So that 15-minute read time even if I implement
it the models are now saying that hey you have a
problem you need to go resolve this through some
other mechanism and in this case instead of just
dumping that problem in my lab vector is smart
enough where it is actually going in and looking
at what are the other possible ways through
which you can solve out of this issue and in
this case it's looking at some models these are
optimization models that are saying if you just
flow your lines a little bit differently you have
a really good solution right so that's what we are
going to do. We're not done yet though, right? So
from a customer's experience, um we need to make
sure that any solutions, any augmentations of the
schedule can operate not just on beautiful blue
sky days that we see here in California most of
the times, but also on gray sky days, right? When
there are thunderstorms uh that are happening. So
we have integrated network simulation models in
the background that are constantly stressing
our network. They're stressing our schedules
and they're trying to evaluate where are the
choke points, where are the break points in
the network. So as you can see on the screen, uh
it had identified a potential problem and at the
same time if you if you follow the pattern here,
it's also going to make recommendations on other
edits that I need to do so that I can actually go
ahead and fix out of it or solve out of it. This
would be a terrible demo if that that uh did not
turn green. Um but this is an actual example and
as a consequence of this right so the the initial
proposition was you can save costs by retiming a a
particular flight and you had to work through a
whole bunch of layers on other constraints that
you have to go solve for and foundry sort of
guiding our analysts guiding our scheduulers
all the way through at the end of it I'm now
confident that the solutions or the schedules
that I'm putting out for you are safe, they're
reliable, and they're profitable at the same time.
that I'm gonna hand it over to Wan. So you saw the
the focus that we've had with Foundry has been on
driving those efficiencies out of the network and
a great example that Amit walked through through
crew but the potential for this is a lot bigger
and we want to expand their use of Foundry into
this integrated planning platform to network
planning all the way to all of our operational
planning teams and really collapse the workflows
to find more areas for efficiencies like we have
so far. We're incredibly excited. It's just been
about a years'sl long journey. Like I mentioned,
tens of millions of dollars already saved and we
can't wait for what's next. Thank you. [Applause]